all right guys bang-bang I've got Sam
here we got a whole bunch of [ __ ] to
talk about you guys are absolutely
killing the game thanks for coming to do
this thank you I'm excited this all came
together cuz you tweeted I'm in New York
and I've nothing to do who wants to meet
and I was quick with the trick the
Twitter fingers yeah and in that like
same Twitter thing tweet storm I said I
was gonna be here and someone's like
host a meet-up and I was like ok we'll
do it for our trend subscribers and we
got like a couple hundred people who
RSVP'd and so we had to trim it down to
20 yeah yeah so we'll see what happens
tonight let's talk about your life
before the hustle
yeah what what did you do where did you
come from well you said you're from the
south right yep I grew up in st. Louis
Missouri and then when I was 18 I moved
to Nashville Tennessee for college okay
where'd you go - no I wasn't good enough
I went to the worst version overpriced
below average school called Belmont
University
aren't they all below average and
overpriced no I think that a top 10 or
top 20 University I think it's worth it
actually like I'll tell my kids like go
to state school or go to Ivy League okay
it's one of the other yeah kind of a
bell curve type right approach to life
uh-huh
and my wife went to an Ivy League school
and I see the benefits and she's smarter
she's very smart and I got a
track-and-field scholarship so I was
fine with their support like what a
400-meter okay
Tyrone Ross claims to be the fastest guy
in all of tech and finance you might
have to give a little race what what's
he run I wasn't what's Israel I don't I
400 run fast anymore but I bet I would
beat him so he this is the part where I
sandbag little bit he was training for
the Olympics and I think he got hurt or
something but I think if I had to set
this up people would pay because how old
is he uh I'm gonna guess he's late 20s
to early third thing I know that name
I mean I ran like 47 40
the 400 which is better than most it's
pretty fast I was a spectacular high
school runner an average college runner
yep but if you're an average d1 athlete
you likely can be a normal person but I
don't this guy's my son we're gonna set
this up now I'm trying to get fit but it
depends how fit he is so you go to
school track and field yeah then I met
this guy named Mike Wolfe remember that
maybe do you from the South deal no
American Pickers yeah hey so the main
guy Mike I met him on the street and I
was a fan and I just walked up to him in
a way yeah it started shoot the [ __ ] and
he was like I'm opening up the store
here we're gonna record here I go Mike
let me work there let me run it yeah he
was like well not run it but come work
okay so I worked there and American
Pickers for those they don't know is a
show on television where they basically
went to like random people's backyards
yeah ages whatever if my old motorcycles
old car's gas pumps anything old and
cool that ever cool [ __ ] they could find
yeah like things that you would see in
like an Americana style home yep we
would rents up to music videos country
music videos just cool stuff and it was
the second most popular show on cable at
the time Wow yeah it was it went like
Pawn Stars American Pickers and then
like David Letterman what does that say
about our society they're number one
I mean those guys are rednecks and I'm a
redneck so I could say it but it's
really educational yeah we had children
from all over the world that would come
people loved it well so my favorite part
about Pawn Stars actually was it has
very similar elements like a shark tank
because there's the negotiation factor I
think people really really add a lot to
the negotiating yeah I mean look it's a
it was like appears like this like one
thing but in reality it's a educational
family-friendly it was great programming
and people loved it and we would have P
was a small store maybe 4,000 square
feet maybe 3,000 pretty small but we
would get thousands of people who would
wait in line who come from all over the
world lying around the block yeah and
and it was in an area without a lot of
stuff and so I was like I should do
something about this so I opened opened
up a hotdog stand that expanded to
multiple locations it was called
southern Sam so we nurses big as a
baby's arm yeah that's where I learned
how to do marketing and where did that
name come from and the slogan who
thought of that you yeah I don't know
he's getting that we would like give
people with discounts if they put their
baby's arm in a bun mustard on it and it
was like this funny
and so what years
this pre or post social media being
popular right around 2010 okay alright
so people could be sharing it on
Facebook or whatever yeah I don't even
think it's Graham was around or maybe it
just started but yeah that was the point
and so I open that up and then I started
playing around the internet and I
learned how to make money on the
internet like I would opened up like
little ecommerce stores that would do
okay and I was like the Internet's where
it's at and so I was a Jun junior senior
in college and I was like I need to move
to wherever the internet people live
which I had never been to California I
didn't know anything and Internet people
where yeah and I there was this runner
named Chris Lukasik I don't know if I
ever even said this his runner named
Chris Lukasik and he was a professional
runner and he quit running at his peak
to join this thing called air
bed-and-breakfast and I was like hey
what's this thing about and so I emailed
the founder and got a job interview and
he was like yeah you could work here
come work here and so I dropped
everything and moved out to San
Francisco and and Brian Chesky was who
emailed Joe kept Joe yeah um and it
turns out the day that's why I left
school sold everything I hadn't
graduated yet I got out there and the
Sunday before I supposed to start they
go you your job was rescinded your job
offer
we took it away and it was because I
lied on my resume I had a criminal
record I had a misdemeanor I didn't tell
the truth and so I did not tell the
truth but like I somehow like vaguely I
was like yeah technically I'm telling
the truth but they caught it yep um so I
saw are you like oh [ __ ] what are you
thinking I was there's about three hours
where I was just so depressed and no it
actually happened on a Saturday and I
was flying out that day and my mom had
come down to help me move out okay and
we and I was with her when we found out
and she was like just get on the plane
anyway you'll figure it out so I flew
out there what a great mom it's very
supportive and she in and she goes just
start it start something when you get
out there you'll figure it out so I went
out there I started a I met a guy just
randomly and he had was a few months
into starting a project I joined him as
a co-founder and it was a roommate
matching company okay not sophisticated
made it okay money but we sold it for a
little bit of money not a lot like tens
of thousands hundred thousands and then
after that is when I met Eric bond who
you and I were talking about and he had
a conference called hustle con and I
knew I knew Eric sorry but I knew
from when I worked at Facebook had no
clue that he had the conference I just
knew yes you know call you Facebook it
was small maybe like 50 or 100 feet
I don't remember how many people but it
was a pretty small thing and I was like
Eric I but like what do I do
what should I do and he was like well I
got this thing you could kind of play
with and so I kind of I took the
original idea that he had in the domain
name and I kind of changed it a little
bit and I launched this thing called
hustle calm which is like a TED talk ish
for entrepreneurs that's how I explained
to my parents who didn't understand this
game but it was like a conference for
non-technical founders and it was called
hustle hustle con which the whole idea
of a calm hustle in some people listen
to this won't remember when the days
when the word hustle was not a bad word
was like hustler or see a thief yeah
well there it was a get bell curve right
like there was days where hustler was a
bad thing they were gonna steal your
wallet then it was like if you're a
hustler that means that you're just
super ambitious self-starter like you're
gonna go knock down doors and be
successful and then it kind of went into
like the hustle porn world of like
everyone's a hustler and you know if you
use that word then also now you're a bad
person
yeah right so this was in like the
Twilight gems of the word hustle yeah
and I think that we've done good with
the word but it it was good it's so like
I I quit my job and on the on the first
day that vesting were ended and I
started this thing and the idea was I'm
just gonna do it to kill time and until
I find my next business and I launched
it on June 1st and the event was on July
15th or something like that I only had
six weeks and I use an email newsletter
I'm a self-taught copywriter I got
really good at copywriting through a lot
of self-practice and everything and it
made like 60 grand I was like that's
kind of cool let's do it again that's
more than like half of America makes
yeah it was great it was really great
and I didn't know that I was gonna make
money if I didn't mean to I mean I did
not mean to but it just was better than
expected
and I did it again this next time I made
like a quarter of a million and so and
how how long are you waiting in between
iteration I did the first one and I
started working on it in June I did it I
took the money and put most of it in the
bank I gave myself five grand and I went
and traveled the country on my
motorcycle for like five months because
I'm American picker style yeah that's
what I did I just
and I camped and I just did nothing okay
I just explore
read books and well do and at the time
are you like I [ __ ] made it like are
you like I came all the way here and a
little I made 60 K my mother I had
already made a little bit of money from
my other thing yet so like I was like
cuz I was like a little bit of a weirdo
in high school in high school because I
was always making money on YouTube or
selling [ __ ] and I was like [ __ ] those
guys like I did it if I was gonna say
whatever you want and then like my high
school wrote an article about it I was
like gotcha
cuz they were I was not a great student
so there they were right but I was an
[ __ ] every bad student who ends up
doing anything successful has that
moment where something that their high
school does to like recognize them
because they want to promote their
alumni right you're like man if the
people reading this right now only knew
that the teachers thought I was gonna be
nothing but whatever look they were I
mean I was not innocent I was just I was
a punk because I was an angry teenager
but I was very happy when if it started
working out so yeah it that's what my
sergeants a little bit of um a little
bit of Fame amongst my like hundred
friends or something like you know they
like knew like oh maybe this guy is he's
doing okay and so on that trip I read
the biography of Ted Turner yep oh it's
a great one yeah he's from the south I
was from the south kind of Missouri
Tennessee he would say hold on a second
can we count Missouri as the south up
here they'll call it that
Oh in New York yeah well anything south
of like Pennsylvania yeah that's like
that kind of I identified as a Tennessee
in because I lived there for a long time
that's fair okay like Missouri folks are
not to you but to like Californians
they're kind of redneck II and I embrace
that yeah the only other person in tech
that I know from st. Louis is Jack
Dorsey right yeah and Sam Altman ah yeah
yeah that's good crew to beer yeah Jack
grew up in my neighborhood or went to
high school my neighborhood so yeah not
really the south but to some people it
is maybe technically it's south of the
mason-dixon line I don't know it was a
it wasn't a slave state so okay who
knows yeah yeah all right
so okay so you ride around on your
motorcycle and I read his book and I was
like this guy's from the south and he's
kind of like shoots from the hip and he
at CNN and I don't care if you're a Fox
News guy or a CNN guy what you can't
deny is that CNN has impacted culture
absolutely and that was really
fascinating to me because when I was on
my trip I would go really poor parts of
Nevada poor parts of Alabama poor parts
of California all over the world and I'm
like well I've been living in California
with all these sophisticated people yet
like we're all the same we're all just
people it the the difference in cultures
couldn't be more contrasting well yeah
well the part that's so crazy miss
dorita
was it a hillbilly geology yeah
radiology elegy I don't know he always
make fun because I can't say that word
there in the Appalachian Mountains and
like you people like that yeah and you
read this thing and you're like you know
what like actually a big portion of the
population lives in a similar type of
situation it's very different than a San
Francisco New York LA or whatever but at
the end of the day we're all humans and
we all actually share a lot of the same
interests we share a lot of the same
desires the bias the same amount of
people and every place to look for
example people always say in the South
it's all redneck go to Birmingham
Alabama it's all hipsters go to Austin
Texas it's all hipster go to Portland's
all hipsters go to the suburbs of
Birmingham but the suburbs of Portland
it's just families who are just trying
to pay the bills and raise good kids go
to the rural part of Oregon the roll
part of Northern California the rural
part of Texas and it's just rednecks
it's all the same [ __ ] yep right and
when I did I talked a little different
Nietzsche not even go up north in
California and they've got southern
accents go to Bakersfield and they all
talk the same yeah it's kind of weird
like and so during this trip I was like
I want to create something big that can
impact all these people or get really
rich where like I can like have my I
just want to have a big impact to impact
people out here and not just in San
Francisco and not just New York but
everywhere and so there's two ways to do
the media thing either you build it from
scratch and you make it successful or
you're the richest man that were like
bassist used by The Washington Post
there yeah one of those things is really
interesting and so I decided to I did
hustle count again and that was in April
so I waited nine months about I did
again and that made money and I was like
I'm using all this money I'm I started
wait years the nation company like
2016/17 yeah okay yeah stand create the
information
yeah and then so we launched the hustle
we originally launched it in fall of
2015 and but in earnest we really went
at it in April of 2000 whatever it is
we're gonna be four years old this April
okay sixteen yeah so in earnest and not
a mathematician yeah 20 minus 4 is
definitely 16 April 19th of 2016 that's
when we really went hard so I can so so
as a project off and on I've been
working on this for a while
yep as a the company that we're known
for now April 2016
mm-hmm okay and the original idea is
what when you say I'm gonna go for this
information well the original idea was
I'm gonna build up this huge audience of
entrepreneurial type folks people who
want to put their debt in the world
through business and then I want to
create more products for them okay
and I didn't want to raise money and so
I did a ton of research and I realized
that two things one email was the best
platform to build a business on because
it wasn't owned by one person you know
if you build one you build a business on
Facebook it's like you are building your
store where the real estate or the
landlord up see it ups it rent every
month I was like okay not gonna do that
so email support Facebook's case they
take away real estate as you continue
trying to girl yeah they decrease the
reach and make you pay and so the only
person who's allowed to say that because
I ran along with a number of other
people the growth team for Facebook
pages and I saw it in real time
oh you ran that as people were
complaining yeah I was the product
manager we had an engineering manager
etc you know kind of a cohort of people
leading this team and Facebook I said to
people hey come on like put your
business you know creoles content and
then over time it not intentionally not
to hurt the businesses but it's just
more more businesses join there's only
so much just to find a man yeah exactly
but what if the small business a small
business person is out there with a
pitchfork like you took away my reach
yeah I'm not anti Facebook I don't own a
lot of Facebook stock I love Facebook I
pay them a lot of money I love Facebook
but like what happens you have this
player former sweather it's Facebook
Twitter Google were yeah they're just
one in the game and so oh so I looked at
the reach on Facebook and all that and
rented real estate but then I also saw
another thing which is if you talk to a
lot of econ folks they'll tell you that
email is the most powerful channel so
like I'm gonna build up this huge
audience of like-minded group of people
and I'm gonna monetize with email
advertising because the email address
are super high because it's because it
has the highest click-through rates and
the most engagement and then I'm gonna
create more products and services for
that one group of people and then we use
all the profit from my advertising
business to launch those to that
audience and hopefully reach world
domination
sorry I'm a female so you saw this much
earlier than most people saw but
basically what this whole idea and this
is coming we there's a million examples
we can talk through is the idea of if
you build a really rabid engaged like
highly kind of powerful audience once
those people subscribe to what you stand
for what you're doing et cetera there's
all kinds of different ways to monetize
that Audis yeah the easiest example is
look at the Kardashians mmm-hmm you know
though I always forget their names but
the Jenner woman who is a billionaire
Bruce Jenner yep [ __ ] with a mom I'm
dumb about the daughter the one who has
the makeup that solver Kylie yeah okay I
think I'm taking a quiz right now all
right go ahead
hi Lee Jenner she had one with Instagram
and she sold makeup on it and it became
a multi hundred million dollar a year
business that was valued at multiple
billion dollars yep that's the game it's
really it's very simple that's what we
were gonna do and so how do you grow so
you start this email how do you grow the
email because what will say hey that's
great idea I'm gonna go do that but they
don't get to a million subscribers so
when I started this industry this
business and kind of still I knew
nothing about media okay
nothing that's actually probably to
advantage that it was a totally an
advantage because people would be like
wow you're breaking the rules I'm like I
don't [ __ ] know what the rules are
I'm not trying to be a badass I just
don't know anything I'm an idiot
yeah and but what I knew how to do from
years of studying and years of selling
hot dogs and years of just salesmanship
is I knew how to get people to believe
what I wanted them to believe I knew how
to capture that it's a fantastic skill
look that sounds negative but I'm using
it in a good way
but I knew how to I get people to I knew
how to capture their attention in their
emotions so Scott Adams has done a
fantastic job over the last couple of
years dissecting this idea of like
weapons-grade persuasion right so you do
a trump-like here's why Trump is and so
I knew how to do that just by talking to
someone I knew like um
what to do and so I was a self-taught
copywriter I liked myself in the bedroom
for six months and I would just take the
best-selling books best-selling sales
pages of all time and I'll copy them out
by hand and that's why I learned how to
become a really good copywriter and so
like when you're doing that what are you
learning exactly so you think about this
do you play an instrument I can drum on
the table but that's about it
okay well if you learn how to play
guitar usually what you do is you don't
like start writing songs so you start
learning other people's music whether
it's sheet music or you like turn Green
Day on you like Billy Joe we're see
putting his fingers okay I'll learn in
that song yep and I'm gonna learn Jimi
Hendrix and then Nirvana and you start
seeing the patterns that make a
successful song and then eventually you
say alright I understand what I like and
I understand best practices for this
type of genre and this type of genre I
can combine here here here and make my
own song
that's what copywriting that's my
methodology for my copywriting so I like
alright any books that you remember
being like wow I learned a ton from that
one yeah so Stephen King on writing is a
great book and then Catcher in the Rye I
just wrote that out and then a ton of
sales pages so like sale like sales
letters from the 50s 60s and 70s when
they used to mail people stuff to get
them to buy like an encyclopedia I found
all the best selling ones and I copied
them all out by hand Oh interesting okay
and so really it was just a repetition
of actually handwriting and I think I
have a notebook it's not too here if I
remember this science correctly there's
a lot of studies that show if you sit
and you write something down you
actually remember it much higher that is
type it or it's called copy work it's a
learning technique that we actually used
to use in public schools but for some
reason we went away with it because it's
really boring and not fun but it's very
effective
Benj Benjamin Franklin used to write
about this he was like yeah here's how
you learn it's really effective okay
it's not like I'm smart I'd stole that
so you're doing this you begin learning
the copywriting skill we're where do you
go from there yeah so I knew how to like
write content I mean I think that I was
born with that talent and I harnessed
skill I learned the skill you enjoyed it
probably a little bit I enjoyed the
result unfortunately more than the
journey but I I was willing to do it and
it was it was kind of fun it was like a
love-hate thing okay
and so I mean it's always fun being good
at something and I was pretty good at it
so I learned how to get traffic to a
website in doing that I knew what
emotions would get people to share
things and I studied it like crazy
just like when I would look at upward
what's it called upworthy remember that
clickbait oh yeah that thing was massive
what are they doing how do they do that
okay so I lordly for those I don't know
was basically a site where they would
find viral videos online they would put
it in there like very specific rapper
and yeah believe number seven like the
top 10 scariest photos from the 9/11
tragedy number four will make you cry
yep so that's a famous tagline it's
called it's from a sales page that the
Wall Street Journal didn't add in and
then the ad said they laughed at me when
I told them I could play the piano well
and then I sat down and started playing
and the point is like the story of how
he when he started playing they all
started loving him and I should learn
how to play piano that's what it comes
from it comes from that famous headline
and so I learned copywriting and so I
started writing a ton of blog posts and
the first month or two we got almost a
million people to the website okay these
aren't normal blog posts yeah it's not
like hey here's how you send a cold
email know what want to do something
like that
but the most the first blog post we ever
wrote was I knew a guy who was making 50
or 60 grand a month gaming the Kindle
system and what he would do is he would
plagiarize best-selling books on how to
sleep with women and then he would
either just put a sexier cover and then
buy reviews or he would send it to the
Philippines they would rewrite it and
then he would put it back up and he was
making a lot of money and I was like
that's pretty scammy but basically what
he was doing is he won discovered a
system he learned how to hack it and
then he basically but not himself
usually he actually had a whole team
that he was using right so he didn't
have do any work yeah and I was like
that's really I don't like that but it's
like I love it and I don't like it you
know I mean I'm like this like a juicy
story
yeah it's things were it's almost like I
loved the initiative
I loved the mentality I hate the
execution yeah yeah could you take that
same skillset and applied it you'd be so
much better off in like exactly and so
we wrote about that the first week in
the second week we me and my co-founder
John did he know you wrote it by the way
yeah we did was he happy
we know one could track it to him okay
gonna use fake names and then the next
week we um
romance novels has the most liquidity in
the marketplace and so more people buy
it and so it was weird it was like the
top categories were like women who
wouldn't have sex with werewolves women
who want to have sex with black guys
women who wanted to have sex with
military men and so we just like
plagiarized some book and put a cover
that kind of combined like where what
black werewolves army sex okay but you
were using data to figure out what it is
I mean data and like we just scanned it
every day and like what's going on here
and so we wrote a book we became a
best-seller book we gained this as
someone we came in bestseller and
colonel and then the joke was we put in
our LinkedIn best-selling author yep
love captivating Claire that was a man
but there's a lot of people who have
done that yeah and so it's like that's
cami but let's do it and so we got a ton
of traffic from that cuz you wrote like
a how-to how do we do this yep right and
I'm sure I watch you really go [ __ ] like
that yeah a lot of hate for it and but
the people who we wanted to love it
loved it and that's how we got our first
five or ten thousand subscribers in a
week okay and so when you're doing this
it's one thing to write a blog post you
get a bunch of traffic how do you
actually inside of that blog post get
them to sign up for so that's another
copy or anything you have to understand
it's you probably you may or may not
notice ADA attention interest desire
action we say it again ADA a I da
interest desire action okay attention
grab their attention and and and do
something it can't be shocking or
anything grabs their attention get them
interested by giving them the go down
the slippery slope and tell them
interesting facts about whatever it is
make them desire it by telling them
benefits and features of this product
and then get them to act by specifically
and clearly explain what to do got it
okay and so I would have pop-ups that
follow that formula or the whole website
would follow that formula where it would
be like a pop-up that said oh [ __ ] that
got your attention and then the interest
was okay look you get a ton of popups in
your life but this one will be will be
meaningful or like it if you and if you
don't like it email me and I'll demo you
a dollar okay so that you're interested
now like you're like curious so desire
this website I don't remember so I'm
making this up this website is acts like
you should enter email for these reasons
just enter your email right here and
check your email box in one minute and
you're gonna get the best damn
confirmation email you've ever read
mmm-hmm like something like that yep and
then people basically it's almost like
they can't resist seeing what the
confirmation email exactly yeah so
that's all kind that's and then the and
then the confirmation email was really
really clever and if you actually who
will the hustle welcome email loads of
people right
about it so that's how but but but then
when we are starting
we weren't even a daily email like I was
still trying to figure out what the
business is and what were you doing we
are out just blogging a ton and then
every week two times a week I would
email up the new blog posts pretty smart
okay yeah and then I was like wait a
minute
let's just only make it an email because
the math works out to where 50% of
people are opening up our emails and
only 10% of those people click through
like let's just give them all the
information but email yeah like who
cares like your phone's a phone like the
phone is the same size no matter what
who cares if they're not Safari or in
the in the mail app yep like if I have
their attention let's so here's my
question is when you make that switch
there's a lot of people who say I don't
want to move all of my content to the
email because now all of a sudden people
can't discover it on the web were you
still posting it on the web as well as
well as and yeah but not a lot of people
would use it and so that smidge that and
then they had to subscribe yep you know
it basically just forced people into
that and now and what it also does I
guess is it takes you from will pull to
a push type relationship with where with
the user because now you're actually
sending it to them when you want rather
than have to go to your website and pull
the content yeah exactly yeah
okay so you get to five ten twenty
thousand subscribers kind of early
you're blogging the first year was some
number between 100 and 200 that's pretty
good it was good yeah it's all through
blogging yeah I don't think we spent a
dime okay on marketing at what point do
you decide one to do paid marketing and
then to D do any referral stuff at oh
when I launched hustle con I hacked
together this referral program where
people would refer someone and if they
bought a ticket they would get 50 bucks
so if I get you to buy ticket a bunch of
different schemes I loose it you know
there were some schemes like if you get
a hundred friends to enter their email
you get a free ticket if you get someone
to buy ticket you get $200 did you track
it it was really ghetto I mean our
conferences the second the first one I
did have 350 the second one that's 600
so it wasn't that hard to track it just
in a spreadsheet yeah it was it wasn't
very hard it goes back to the idea that
I think a lot of people when they see
some of this stuff like oh my god the
Hustle is so smart like they use all
this technology but whatever and you're
like music rachel by the way i'm super
not technical ya know it's those
spreadsheets like I built this thing I
paid my friend 500 dollars to build it
and he built
in such a way that I could just go on
Heroku click export' then sort and match
like it was like this like really like
hacked together it wasn't sophisticated
or I don't kind of stuff escape it not
really okay so you're doing that you've
got the referral program and then at
some point you say hey let's do paid ads
what was the decision process there to
certain because I knew early on what an
email could be worth I knew early on
that like I did the math oh my god if
they stay for this long which I think
they will and we charge this much for
advertising and our fill rate is 90% and
email could be worth X can I go out and
quire an email for cheaper than that and
so I would spend a few dollars and I
would get that and then I would spend
more and more and more and that's kind
of how it worked and at the same time
that you're spending more and more in an
aggregate kind of investment were you
also driving down the CAC of each email
oh yeah right so you're getting much
better at it as well so your dollar
becomes more efficient on the spend side
got it but I won't use up spending a lot
of money then it goes up of course and
this is all through like Facebook and
Google or were you finding really niche
platforms as well at first I was it was
a one-man show or two-man show is me and
John and Cara and like two or three
other people so I didn't have a lot of
bandwidth it yeah and I didn't know
anything like I had to learn Facebook
like yep on the fly so no we sponsored
mostly one or two channels got a Twitter
link just a big programmatic ones yep
and then as you're doing this and now
we'd spend all over the place other
emails we've even tried billboards
everything and as you're doing this how
are you measuring whether it's working
or not like I think one of the big
things is like it's very authentic for
you to be like oh I didn't know what I
was doing like we were just kinda like
throwing much stuff at the wall and were
you just looking at like oh there's more
people signing up for the email list so
like things are going well also I knew
the math behind it I always because we
are bootstrapped I like every dollar how
to turn into more dollars every dollar
spent to turn in more dollars and I knew
the math behind it I I'm I'm ah well
modeled out what the business could be
and I was like I think this could like
this business could work I mean it made
sense and then so half that answer is
well this is the math just works out
that this will work and then the other
half is emotional and like some days it
was like no way this can't work and then
other days it was like
think it's working so the math always
showed that it could work but and then
emotionally I was like oh yeah we got a
lot traffic it's go to work and then
other days like huh it's not gonna work
and around this time Business Insider
sold for six hundred million dollars so
I was like Henry Blodgett yeah yeah I
was like wild story about Henry though I
don't know he was bored from the
financial yeah I know all about him yeah
yeah tell you all about him okay so and
he started that company with Kevin Ryan
you know that is I do not who's that
Kevin where's Kevin Ryan's idea Kevin
Ryan founded gilt he founded MongoDB
which is publicly traded he founded
Edward or he's the CEO of Adwords before
it's sold to Google it was called
double-click and then changed Adwords he
sold uh you know Zola mm-hmm he started
that Wow yeah so he's been around yeah
like I said I did research I know like I
know all these guys because I would just
call evil I'm like crazy well the part
that would Blodgett that was so
interesting was I think he was a
financial analyst he basically got
barred he kind of a scapegoat a little
bit yeah and he got barred for basically
what I think a lot of people were doing
at the time was they would write
publicly to like clients and say like
you know hey we have a by rating on this
stock and then internal emails which
should then be like this is a [ __ ]
stock right so it was kind of like
they're saying one thing publicly one
thing negatively which a coordinate of
the rules is wrong but it was more of
like a everyone's doing it it's wrong
it's not enforced and then all sudden
like we need two or three people don't
like clamp down on yeah and look he
didn't trade again but he still crushed
it so good for him
well so when he started I think was
silken alley alley first right there was
a big debate like is he allowed to do
this cuz he's technically talking about
stocks and finance and whatever I didn't
own it as long as he didn't own and long
didn't manage money and so it was a way
for him to basically put that knowledge
that he had to work right and he's got a
six hundred million dollar company he's
great he's real smart and very it's
great writer so those guys sold and I
was like something's here I think I
could I just usually when I start stuff
and now I like own a couple other
businesses or a part owner and some and
invest in a little bit like I usually
like so I think of like alright step one
step two is this SEP 10 is like maybe
you'll be bigger than Business Insider
maybe I could turn this into Fox and own
like all these things maybe this could
be a Gartner or something huge but and
just to get close to that I'm gonna do
this email thing and then I'll just make
money off of it and then steps three
four five and six
I'm like I don't know what those steps
are but I figured I'm super confident
I'll figure it out dude I mean yeah yeah
but I think it's the perfect balance
between like I kind of know like what my
North Stars like where I'm going right
it's like I want this to be really big
but if I try to jump to step five or six
then like I'm screwed because I'll never
start one and two but I literally just
start like let's start walking right
let's do step one step two all of a
sudden like it becomes clear what step
three is yeah yeah that comes clear
that's what holds a lot of people back
so it's like I'm gonna drive like
there's a huge mountain 20 miles away
I'm gonna drive towards it and I know
that I just have to uh there's I can
only make a left right here so I'll make
a left and then when I get there I'll
figure out to it you know yeah it's one
of these things where a lot of times
founders will come to me but have this
idea about whatever and one of the
things I always say to them is what is
the one thing that you think that you
could accomplish in the next three weeks
right or the next four weeks and usually
it's like dumb stuff like oh I could get
the website build or I could do that you
know like whatever it is it's not
something that's like actually material
to what their end goal would be but I'm
like if you can get that done I bet that
you're then personally interested enough
to then go to the next step yeah and
I've done I've started enough businesses
that run a successful a small-scale to
know to learn like you figure it out you
know it's like when I travel now I'll
just like show up and I'm like we'll get
a hotel we'll figure it out I'm
perfectly fine winging it most
everything so but this also brings I
think Silicon Valley is the best in the
world at doing this where it's kind of
like this experimentation iteration type
mentality where people will start things
and there's not a lot of pressure on it
either right like it for most businesses
around the world if you go and you talk
to entrepreneurs who want to start these
businesses they literally now will be
like I want to build a ten billion
dollar business and here's like my grand
plan to get there and whether it's a
business plan or some sort of dec like
they've got this very specific this is
what I'm gonna go do I think more the
Silicon Valley mindset it is like hey
I'm King curring with this thing it
seems to kind of be working uh I think
we can make a little bit of money on it
and like I think that it could be bigger
but like we're gonna figure it out well
cool [ __ ] a lot of cool [ __ ] start small
Airbnb when they have their pitch deck
they're like we think this could become
a hundred million dollar company that's
what Jeff Bezos said he goes I think I
think if we're lucky we might be able to
become a hundred million dollar company
yeah
like it's and that's like he just spent
more than that on the house
totally and I listened to an interview
with their first investor madona what's
the fun I forget madrone madrone and
that's what he said he goes Jeff said
you know we might be able to sell
hundred million dollars with the stuff
crazy so and that's like a big number
yeah so yeah and I think both work like
Peter Thiel he's like [ __ ] don't iterate
have this grand vision and and so both
both work but what regardless you have
to be flexible and and that's hard for
and I think part of the like the Peter
Thiel Keith were boys like those guys
who what they believe is almost like you
you know what you want to build and you
bend the world to you right versus other
people who say hey I'm gonna start doing
this and then I'll kind of figure it out
as I go I actually don't think those two
things are that dissimilar right I think
that they're actually very very similar
because one is more of like a vision
type I know what I want to build and
then the iteration stuff I'll figure out
along the way versus somebody's more
focused on the iteration and they don't
know yet what it'll become but when you
put this to get similar boat you gotta
be bold for both of them and you learn
along the way for both of them it's it
is a little similar I mean like because
I didn't have a lot I wanted to do this
one so I could get like a hit now that
I've had a hit maybe my next one I'll
raise a ton of money or I'll bet a lot
of my money and just be like [ __ ] it
let's bet at all
yep and that will be exciting but
regardless I'll learn along the way and
kind of deviate slightly did you think
that starting the media sigh was really
risky no not at all why not cuz I felt
like like most people would have said I
have something that works I'm making
some money on the conferences why would
I ever start doing something else and
spend money to do so I did it the other
way around
I had this conference I know it works if
the media side fails I can always do
that there was the other way around
it was like I work and always the hot
dogs or I actually saved $500 I was like
I'll fly home and live in my mom's house
so you are very similar to a kind of the
classic founder who looks at risk very
differently than most people right
because most people who have like a
corporate job would look at that risk
and say there's no way I can take this
risk instead you're like look if I take
this risk and XYZ goes wrong I'm all dis
interruption well I look at there's two
different ways that I convince myself
all the time to do it cuz I have to you
you get scared sometimes the first is if
I fail and everyone sees it they're
gonna want to hire me and I'm saying a
media company by definition I gotta get
a lot of eyeballs everyone will know me
and if I fail I'm gonna get a job
yep every corporation loves to hire the
failed entrepreneur because ya know that
they're super ambitious they're
resourceful etc yeah I was like I'll be
able get a job probably and I've like
never really had like a normal job I was
like I'd be that'd be like put a noose
on my neck but like whatever and the
second thing was I always want to
protect the downside and so with what I
mean by that is in my head so I'd like
slept outside before when I had some
issues and I was like so worst-case
scenario I'll sleep outside I was like
did I like that
I didn't love it but I would do it so
what's like a step up from that well
what I'd be willing to like tell my
parents I totally failed and and they
would accept me I guess
okay okay love it I'll accept that
that's a fine downside
therefore I found the lowest I could go
and so I set aside $500 and I was like
they're the downsides protected this is
the emergency fund to get home yeah I
was like there's nothing to worry about
yeah like I have just accepted that the
worst case my I've accepted already the
worst is going to happen I've planned
for it I have no downside yep that's how
I look at it so you've now grown this to
over a million subscribers yeah so well
over was in on two million soon we're
yeah and yeah it's up there and it we
add like on a good day like tens of
thousands of new people a day it's
awesome and it's a good company it's
eight figures in revenue Oh at all
advertising until recently when you
added subscription yeah so I do the plan
was the beginning from the beginning was
built this massive audience and start
selling stuff for them and when I
started my company I did loads of
research like I just wanted to
understand best practices and I would
read biographies and I would reach out
to experts and I would just interview
them and ask everything I could just so
I could copy what worked and not copy
what didn't work and I could just say
myself years of heartache and so I
realized when we were getting ready to
launch this new product I did the same
process and I started showing advisers
and investors like the reports I was put
together and they're like oh just sell
that
and so I read the book of by getting a
Gartner the guys start Gartner
getting--getting Gartner you know
Gartner is I do the company I wonder the
person ok Gartner it's a big 10 billion
dollar year research thing and they're
like that's a big thing just do that and
I was like oh yeah you're right and I
love doing this research and so we
launched trends so Transco and go sign
up at you psycho and then if you enter
in the code Pompey is pio pio MP yep
you'll get a 50% discount
oh look ops got your back always can you
remind me to make that code I've already
made now why you lose time you're
listening where wasn't it so watched
right yeah so we launched that a little
while ago and that's already a
seven-figure subscription business and
so with this business I think what we
can do is then create a higher end one
for specific to certain industries and I
think that we can build a hundred
million dollar a year business that's
very profitable with 30 percent
advertising 30 percent $300 to $4 a year
subscription business and then a 30 or
50 million dollar a year high-end
subscription business so right now how
much are you charging for trends it's
cheap it's $300 a year and what you get
is we have a team of analysts and what
trends all we do is uncover different
opportunities in the entrepreneurial
world okay and so we do two things the
first thing is we do case studies and
cool and interesting companies or
interesting companies or industries so
for example I went to Vegas and stayed
at the MGM Grand and I was like haha
[ __ ] is this hotel so big this is crazy
and so we went and did a report on the
top 10 biggest publicly traded hotel
businesses and explained like okay so
like the secret sauce is basically not
the secret sauce but the metrics that
matter most is occupancy rate and
average revenue per room and if you nail
those it'll work it's game over and then
we went further and said here are the
top growing sectors that that all the
experts as well as our data has shown
and so it's like different lifestyle
hotels things like that and then the
second thing we do is we've created
technology that crawls the web and finds
really fast growing things so for
example we on alert that sleep so people
are searching for products that make you
sleep better far more than meditation
things that meditation is a huge
business and so we flagged that and we
told our readers about it and then we
wrote where are the opportunities within
the sleep
does sector and who is capitalizing on
it who has interesting opportunities and
interesting businesses and whatever
think will win and then we have a
private community of thousands of people
where you can discuss those and so I fly
around the country and I meet with do
meetups for those groups and all types
of things like that and so who is on the
receiving end of it it's like who's the
ideal trend subscriber is this somebody
who's an entrepreneur and investor Bowl
really wide so it's guys like you and me
her just schemers like I I have my
business but I'm always like tinkering
like people come in here and they pitch
me wild ideas and I literally the more
wild and like ski me that it is right
meaning like I'm gonna hack this
together and this together in this
together and like I have this like
business and like oh you have no
employees and boom or whatever and I'm
like all right let's go trying to figure
that out like that's actually way more
fun than the like I'm gonna go raise
twenty million dollars and I'm gonna go
build this hardware store yeah well I
use scheming positively which is I'm
always like like if you go to a rush if
you're the type of person that goes to a
restaurant and be like if they move that
counter over here so then the parisa
didn't have to turn her back all the way
and only turned her back a little bit
and then put that thing here that
actually they could probably serve a
hundred more customers yes it's actually
resourcefulness it's like what the real
word is but scheming is a way more
memorable wordy schemers I would say ABS
always be scheming and so the the
subscribers are like people like you and
me who are investing in new things or
who I have my own business and so I'm
not gonna start another business now but
I'll apply like what I what what did the
hotel industry do that's cool is they
franchise their stuff maybe I should
franchise my conference is kind of like
the hotel engine you want I mean yep yep
yep so a lot of freelancers a lot of
people who own small businesses a lot of
executives at big companies people who
are just thinking all the time about
optimizing business people ask me all
the time like what content I consume
right and one of the things I tell them
is like my favorite thing to do is read
profiles or biographies on people and
businesses and the reason is because you
don't have them like writing like here's
the lesson plan for today you just see
what they do but I could literally you
could rattle off Ted Turner Sam Walton
ken Langone like you just go down the
line of all of these people I've read
all of those yeah and you learn you
learn so much I love your wife's work
she she she one day says to me she goes
so she's got the profile right and
she's curating all of these and she's
like I really enjoy this work and I was
like why and she never used the word
learned that's basically what she was
saying and what it was so fascinating to
me was she had never thought about
starting a business before she never
thought about any of this stuff and
she's like I feel like I just understand
more about how people build things by
reading their stories more so than I
would get out of reading like here's how
to start a business book or yeah yeah
here's how to be a CEO and so that's
what trends is as we just look at with
case studies yep and take and we make
recommendations but take from it what
you will got it all right I want to talk
about like new media models so I'm gonna
throw a couple of companies out there
that I think you've looked at or have
opinions about and we'd kind of talk
through them so the first is
subsequently the email world that you're
in and so this business you're an
investor no I'm an advisor but the the
business that they are building is
essentially empowering a whole new
generation of people to build a business
that previously they couldn't write so
it removes all the technical friction to
starting these email subscription
businesses now you probably had to build
out a lot of this stuff initially and
now if you were starting again you could
start on a subject to some degree yeah I
sorry my shoes off my blood circulation
here we might have an amputee in the
building they see my feet on camera no
you're good shoeless I got a hold my
boot all right sub stack yeah okay so
that's by the way the grabbing of the
attention we just got everyone's
attention when do you went shoe let's go
ahead sub stack okay so I went to their
office and met with the founders they're
like the type I say it's in a good way
because I'm part of this they're like
nerds yep and those types of people will
win a lot of people don't know Chris BES
who's one of the founders in the CEO
previously was the founder of kik
which I don't know that right so I would
bet on them to win the current iteration
will not win my prediction is why I
think this because I don't think there
are that many people who will have paid
newsletters okay and
definitely won't be a lot of people who
have had $5 a month okay what I think
they could win is by having that as well
as an enterprise version which I talked
to them the other day I go guys I'll
give you $10,000 a month make this and
the Enterprise version would include
what that they currently so right now
like and the reason why I want to tease
this out is this is the exact type of
conversation that I think a lot of
people aren't privy to like this happens
behind closed doors but you're somebody
who says you what I told them everyone
want to give them I tweeted us all time
that okay so the whole media world is
trying a lot of people trying to do
paywalls mm-hmm the way most people do
it is [ __ ] horrible they don't know
what they're doing it in such a bad way
and the software that exists for paywall
there's very few and the ones that do
exist are horrible yeah they were so bad
it's so bad that a lot of people try to
build it in-house
yes right yeah New York Times builds
in-house um and like meanwhile every
bought free blogger uses WordPress a lot
of newsletters use MailChimp why is
there not a good thing that combines all
that like does like a good paywall
software and it's awful you someone get
like I'm not convincing it would be
massive massive I mean it's all relative
but I do think it could be a
billion-dollar company if it hits 100
million like I think it could hit 100
million in revenue and if you're an
enterprise SAS and do that you're
considered a unicorn so if they iterate
to build that I think it could be a lot
bigger okay and it's all about the
enterprise you think unlocks a whole
bunch of revenue that they that they
otherwise couldn't get yeah or or maybe
they could do it the way they're doing
it but they have to change it a little
bit like they have to have proper sales
pages they like I want them to be the
Shopify of paywall of a shop if I have
content mm-hmm
so the one thing and I told them as a
bunch of times that I knew very early on
like whoa these guys are on the right
track right at least and kind of head in
the right direction
I kept pinging them or they only been
the Hickey guys can do this can you guys
do this and they'd always come back with
like a yeah we'll put it down on the
list but not right now so they focused
it was just super super folks and it was
like stupid stuff that I wanted like hey
can you add so that somebody could put
their first name in so when I email them
I can use their first name brother yeah
that has much higher engagement rate
well they were like no good right
because they were just like look this is
what we want to build right and like we
don't care about all the other kind of
things that are nice
have not need to have one I think
they're gonna win even though I think
that their product right now is I think
the product I think it's an amazing
early version yes I drew that and I
think that I think they would agree with
that
yeah and I'm permanent but I would bet
on that because you have to look at
what's what's something can be I mean
they're so yeah I was like two years old
a year old yeah maybe they only have
four four or eight employees yeah they
just hired a couple more they have go to
sub stack comm they have tons of roles
that they're hiring yeah I went to their
office here date was completely empty
yeah and I was like what's going on guys
and they go well we're just getting
ready to hire but we're making sure we
get the right people I love that those
founders I think will win if they
iterate I think they're for sure gonna
win
I would totally bet on them I love it
the athletic for this I don't know is a
subscription sports content site think
kind of like ESPN but you pay 10 bucks a
month 60 bucks a year they went around
the country they found the best local
sports writers at all these local papers
and said hey we'll bump up your salary
why don't you come right for our site
rather than your local paper they got a
bunch of people to do this like 300 plus
of them and they build a really really
big business very quickly I think it
could be great what do you not like
don't like their cap table if I was the
founder which I've talked to a bunch of
times
he was like always having a fund raise
they've raised maybe 100 million dollars
oh really I think yeah I know nothing
about the capital you know many many
tens of millions it's it's took 30
million dollars and bedrock so it's
probably the 100 million range 70
million I bet you the founders own less
than 10 percent each if they don't care
about that great I wouldn't want to be
in that position but the business if if
they say if if what they say publicly is
true it's a 60 million dollar a year
company so that's pretty valuable and
its revenue yeah yeah yeah I think they
said they have a million subscribers in
a sixty bucks a year yeah yeah so it's
really interesting bullish I don't know
if it's I'm bullish yet at a 500 million
dollar valuation but I would fall on the
more optimistic side had you asked me a
year ago or no two years ago I'm in like
that's crazy that's ridiculous why what
why'd you change your mind just cuz they
petitioned revenue it was a horrible
idea most people could never pull it off
and now I think it's the future whoa
okay so unpack that a little bit more
why did you change so radically
I saw the results that we have I saw
that consumers this whole fake news
thing that Donald Trump started I don't
care what you think about him
he's right like oh yeah oh we can go way
down that rabbit hole the reason why
half the country hates that he says it
is cuz they know it's right he's right
and the reason why the other half the
country like said he says it is do they
know he's right he's right I have owned
clickbait websites I was able to get
millions of unique Stu different of
course it's lightweight it's not an
online thing it's not a certain one
publication thing
it's literally if you go to the grocery
store and you pick up one of those like
inquired [ __ ] things they literally
take a photo they put some fake headline
on it they turn it million dollar your
business I believe of course so this has
been around for a very very let's go
journalism I mean Hearst built his whole
empire on that robert rupert murdoch was
accused of doing that this works yeah
and it's not bad always sometimes it's
funny like TMZ i think is the best you
want to hear well i think it's crazy
about TMZ everyone gives him a bunch of
[ __ ] they're always right they were the
very first person to report the kobe
bryant I was on tmz.com right when a
president they're always right yeah and
so I think what it gets to though is
this idea that now with the internet
like people always thought this stuff
was kind of like salacious or
exaggerated or whatever or all the way
to just actually fake now they actually
have the ability to verify that it's
fake yeah yeah and so I think that the
reason why I subscription I'm bullish on
we're doing like b2b subscriptions so I
think that's why we're gonna kill it but
consumers and people consumers and
businesses are willing to pay for
quality information and I didn't do you
think that there's the subscription
model changes the content like the type
of content you create if it's behind the
pl version I'll explain why so some
businesses like what I know how to run a
media business now and I know how they
operate what I would do if I started my
business in 2020 no let's say 2009 when
Facebook started does intent whenever
pages came out what I would do is I
would say each writer you guys have a 1
million page view code ax you have to
hit it every month and then I would go
out and hire a thousand writers and I
would teach him how to write headlines
and I would be able to get that and make
a lot of money that's basically what
BuzzFeed I mean literally but it was a
great business win unless it
yep it's still the cook business to be
honest but it's just that it's maybe not
multi-billion dollar company I mean
Business Insider for the longest time
took other people's articles rewrote a
couple of words put a headline on it
that was better and I didn't shout out
something it worked
yep and want to read the full story
click here yeah and you know what I love
Business Insider it was pretty it was
wonderful
or I think it is it's it served the
purpose that it set out to serve and I
think people appreciate when something
fulfills the brand promise that it yes
and I really dug it and so that that is
one type of content I would say right
get this many pages the best way to get
it is to average 10,000 pages per
article right three articles a day mm-hm
and boom that's it now with subscription
what you can do is you can say you can
write any amount of articles you want
you can write one a year or you can
write one a day I'm gonna see which of
your articles brings in the most new
subscribers and the way that you're
gonna bring in new subscribers is
someone's gonna read your article and so
they're gonna see it's paywall and
they're gonna say or they're gonna have
friends and they're gonna say this is
looks really interesting I'm gonna pull
up my wallet and give you $300 and buy
it and that is the test of quality is it
it's so good they'll buy it and I can
measure all my writers that way how how
much of that content do you think has to
be behind the paywall versus giving it
away for free and then getting people to
subscribe what do you think about my
current opinion and it will change maybe
is 100 percent should be paid off 100
percent how do people find it / know
that it's high-quality so what I mean by
100 percent is maybe like what I mean is
100 percent of the articles not 100
percent of the article so for example
the headline the picture and maybe a
description can be visible got it so
it's kind of like you're teasing them
with a little bit of what is this
article about but if you actually read
the article you got yeah actually and
then I think that the concept of the
publication the concept of the content
the concept of all the other programming
the concept of what the value you're
gonna provide them that needs to be done
in the sales copy and so what do you
think about the model that some of the
mainstream press is taken in terms of
like hey I'll give you 10 articles you
can read 10 for free and then you have
to convert versus just hard paywall
everyone I don't know the results so I
can't actually the data wins but I don't
think that that's a good idea
the
reason why I think they think is gonna
do is to keep doing it yeah but they
also do a lot of dumb stuff that's true
you know what I mean like but even like
the New York Times who I think at this
point is very sophisticated but New York
is different
New York Times is different because
they're not an upstart they're not like
fair you know what I mean like what if I
was seen York Times they're doing a lot
of really good ad campaigns I would say
I would do an ad campaign that says like
or maybe if I was a Wall Street Journal
I'd be like like I would try to campaign
like 16 get your license like 18 go to
college 21 get you have your first drink
25 get your first job subscribe to The
Wall Street Journal yeah like you wanted
me like I would you ad campaigns like
that where it's like oh yeah of course
you have to subscribe yep when you're a
company like me and no one knows who you
are yeah yeah a whole different game
yeah got it you guys just started a
podcast
yeah I thought my first million it's
awesome it's cool it's the best pitch
for a product we've had on the podcast
ever it's so it's awesome it's so fun it
was Sean a friend of mine who sold his
company started it where he would just
interview people about the early days
and that was going fine but then one day
a guest didn't show up and Sean was like
hey come and just riff with me like
we're doing now and I was like all right
let's riff and I got a bunch of trends
reports and I did my own research I like
did research on the executive recruiting
industry I did research on cruise ships
I did research on Boy Scouts I was like
these three business models are really
interesting to me and let me explain to
you why and we started riffing on him
about like I was like what could work is
look this Boy Scouts is declining the
reason it's declining is this thing I
think there's opportunity here and
that's all we do in the podcast and
people love it so now we Scouts just
went bankrupt yeah and I think a big
business can be built there oh for sure
like young we don't turning boys into
men I think it's actually gonna become
more popular because with digital
everyone's like you got to get out you
got to do this and then I wouldn't have
the religion concept of Boy Scouts
because religion is less popular and I'm
like yeah look at the numbers and I like
break out the financials I'm like here's
this this and that's what we do on
trends I just doing the podcast got it
and so as you've grown this both on the
email side and on the podcast talking
about ad sales like how did you guys
initially attack that and how have you
gotten smarter about that so we've had
our events
we're kind of Riis to on how we're doing
on but they were quite big maybe we get
10 or 15 thousand attendees a year
people would pay to cover was free at up
hey hey okay and so I had hundreds of
speakers the founders of massive
companies we work which doesn't hold as
much as it used to but we were casting
at him come Miguel Miguel okay so all
these go there he's cool
yes um Gargery plan is profiling my gosh
she wrote a pretty good pretty fair I
think Pro he's just not hippie yeah he's
cool dude he's like what six eight six
seven like that yeah and uh so when I
first met Polina she I think you're
right before I met her or right after
she wrote an article on there's four
friends from high school that all play
basketball together that all were
running either as the founder or a lead
executive of a billion dollar startup
Miguel AppDynamics was another one and
there was two other guy forget who the
other two guys were but they're four
guys who all played on the same high
school basketball game and I remember
reading article me like what the hell
are they putting in the water over there
they're off well he's a hippie he lived
in the commune um but we had um she had
a bunch of eggs and so when we first
started to the conference the first year
made like three or four or five hundred
thousand dollars and our burn rate each
month for like five employees in an
office was something like twenty five
thousand dollars a month or something
like that and I said alright let's build
this email and then the email is gonna
become bigger than the conference so I
said we gotta get to 30 grand a month in
ad sales to be profitable so I called up
or emailed all the founders who spoke at
the conference and I go guys you know I
know how to execute you know that like
this is a real community put me in touch
with your ad sales people and originally
it was like deals like just give me your
link and I'll put it in there and give
me $500 for every mattress I sell and
then I hired Adam who's not the
president of my company and runs a lot
of the day-to-day operations I went to
high school with him and he built the
sales team from scratch that's just a
bunch of killers and so when you guys
think about how to create the products
that you saw with the actual ad product
itself is it still this like mordy to
see hey here's a link go convert or do
you do brand and both actual response
yeah I mean the ad that we've made tens
of millions of dollars on I just wrote
it out one day and I was like all right
there's the onion it go sell it and it
worked
now it's more sophisticated like our
technology for sending so we have this
thing called our CMS that's not an
appropriate name but we still call it
that but our writers write in it our ad
salesman sees all the inventory we know
how many subscribers we have that day
and we have a projected six month plan
based off of our previous six months and
then we we can see the profiles of all
the subscribers like the demographics
then we send a link to our advertisers
we've worked with thousands of
advertisers advertisers at this point so
sales like we closed let's say
SmartWater we closed SmartWater that
goes into our Salesforce our Salesforce
tells our CMS the CMS automatically
sends them a link they fill a brief that
sends back to us we create the ad they
approve it goes out to people then check
this out the advertiser pays through
that thing and a bank who we have a line
of credit with sees like our accounts
receivable and can loan us money against
that and so that's how we bootstrapped
all company's pretty good it's pretty
cool it's yeah it it's crazy that one of
the things that you said in there that I
think a lot of companies wouldn't do
because again it's taking risk is you
said hey give me the link and you just
hang on what I sell like betting on
yourself right because I think a lot of
people especially when it comes to
newsletters and content except they're
so used to the display model of just hey
pay me two grand and I'll put you some
people like who sell like certain things
like Goldman has advertised with us like
they can't they don't they work yeah had
a manager how many people open the email
did you call Goldman or do they call you
I didn't close that deal I don't I don't
do deals anymore but uh I don't know but
I tell you something funny I could talk
about I probably will get yelled at I
don't give a [ __ ]
we had Goldman but we said we wrote a
story about [ __ ] Jerry yeah oh yeah and
le Ben Kaplan yes yeah and so we thought
it'd be funny just to use the word [ __ ]
like for everything like they really
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] Jerry [ __ ] up by [ __ ] the
customers yeah out of it so Goldman got
mad at us and pulled out because you had
the ad he said yeah we said [ __ ] too
many times yeah that's fine
yeah at least you didn't the f-word yeah
so we got trouble with them but yeah we
have like a team a sales team and some
people we sell on opens but we
definitely have to make money
for them for sure and so as you think
about this now what's next right so you
got trends you'll go eventually and add
a higher tier subscription
you've got the podcast where you go do
more podcast more times basically I look
at our business like a funnel we have
top a funnel which is ad-supported
content so podcast free newsletters
social and things like that and then we
have a little bit lower down the funnel
which is trends that's 299 300 dollars a
year I think in the next handful of
months we're gonna raise it to 600 hours
a year so sign up now with the code pop
so you get 50% yes and then and then we
have one below that and that's our
events events cost hundred dollars
sometimes no as cheap as twenty dollars
all the way up to $2,000 and then one
below that we'll have something that's
10 or 20 grand a year and I want to do
in-depth research for different
industries and companies and then one
below that is I eventually want to
invest or start businesses based off of
interesting insights that we discover so
like what you say with the hotels
basically could you take an insight
you've learned after analyzing the hotel
industry and then go yes I've already
personally invested in things that we
discovered yep but I want to do a key
talk about one of them is there an
example that you can talk about that
isn't yeah I'll talk about one I want
yeah it was a keto ramen these guys yeah
like keto like the like the diet yeah
like low carb ramen okay and because we
were talking about keto cereal people
are searching for cicchitto cereal like
crazy yeah I think there's somebody
who's started to build this magic spoon
and we talk about these months ago in
cereal school and school and we started
like looking at like different ways that
that could be big and it was Brahman and
so I've invested in one of them so you
saw Haila lots of people are buying keto
cereal they're searching for ketose
people searching for where's other
opportunity yep and and keto ramen was a
huge one and they basically went you
found the key to ramen business yeah so
you had to go hunt like I'm always
fascinated by it this one was easy out
front a friend that was already kind of
tinkering okay I worked out well and
they started the business based on your
insight or they were always a
collaboration they were tinkering with a
gum and I'm like yeah you should go for
this plan I just walked in the room we
can't say anything bad about her anymore
another thing was
remember the these apps they're called
it was called hooked we this is where
they were like sending push
notifications it was like part of the
other teens were reading like thrillers
well we analyzed that well the next
message that yeah we're like that's
really interesting but you know it's the
category that grows fastest and has the
most liquidity is romance novels going
back to the black werewolves yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so I invested in a company
that was doing serialized app content
that was paid for and but it was meant
for middle America moms as opposed to
like teens like hooked is yep and so you
basically can just use those insights
which obviously if somebody wants to get
those in size they can go subscribe and
then usually do the same thing you're
doing yeah makes sense we think about
borstal sports you know think about them
I'm fast I'm fascinated by taking the
media model and plugging it into a
massive business like gaming it worked
and I mean this what's the sock - did
you see I did not see how looking up if
it's above 30 the other day was 32 it's
been going up that's for sure I bought a
bunch when they announced it they're 36
its 36 yeah okay it's when they bought
it was 24 20 to 25 96 one month ago but
I think they probably announced it a
little bit after that oh well on the
chart it was 25 42 and then there's a
massive rocket ship up and to the right
of the stock so what's the difference
between 25 and 36 what's that forty
percent yeah something like that
okay so that means that I'm not good at
math so that means it's sold that values
it at around 600 and something million
what pen or borstal barstow I mean what
I mean is okay so we can ever talk about
this ready pen just did this n Tesla
just did this where in both cases they
did something that was a catalyst that
drove the stock price up but the
appreciation of the stock more than
covered what they did so yeah pen bought
barstool no brainer because they
actually made money so they shade a
hundred 150 milli a hundred thirty six
million and then they have an option to
buy the rest the rest but their market
cap no their market cap went up way more
than yeah they had a four hundred fifty
million dollar price target on it and
they have a 300 dollar cap current
market cap is 4.2 billion dollars yeah
so their market cap
more than a billion dollars yes
no-brainer deal for them and then and
then and then they also Portnoy Dave
Portnoy and the company got a ton of
penstock of course so well they're
crushing it so two things about poor
tonight I love the guy uh he's worth a
hundred plus million dollars yeah right
without the appreciation in the stock
and when I might get sued though when
they met well when they announced the
deal he I heard him on a podcast and
he's like I have unlimited money he's
like for a guy like me literally
unlimited money here's looking at me
like yeah actually like given the life
he lived for thirteen years before he
ever raised money before he did anything
with czernin a sold that two years prior
for a fifteen million dollar valuation
or maybe forty four so yeah so churning
came in I think they bought fifty
percent of the business for like seven
seven half a million bucks about fifteen
million dollar valuation but to Eric uh
Nardini and Mike earns and churning all
their credit Dave and Dan although they
had no clue what they were doing for
their idiot so they owned like Erica
says she washes what Erika said she
walked into the UH
their quote-unquote office and there was
like uncashed checks lying around and
she was like guys what are you doing no
I oh yeah we should probably bring that
to the bank
she was like all right like the the bar
of where we're starting is so low like I
could definitely help here and then look
what they did turn in foreigner fifty
million dollar company in four years
yeah so you asked what I think about it
it doesn't really matter what I think
about it it worked
I think it's successful obviously it's
successful it's great what would you do
if you're Erica and Dave with that
business now it's so not I mean it's so
obvious you have a bar stool casino you
have Disney World but for grown men who
want to get drunk and Gamble I mean so I
also think they're gonna open their own
pizza chain yeah I heard that right if
they if they make that move if you go
physical casinos you keep up with the
digital content and you go pizza chain I
would just go and read the biography of
Walt Disney and just do all of that so
like just Rio so you think like even go
like all in on the physical locations
yeah but instead of a theme park you
have a casino
yeah which is basically I just do
exactly what Walt Disney did except for
like 35 and 40 old dudes yeah there's
they have yep so it's not like I'm not
like smart for saying that yeah
Hey look that's obviously good yeah and
then uh Elon did this as well but he
said hey I'm gonna raise two billion
dollars I'm gonna sell a bunch of the
stock and the stock went up eight
billion yeah fine twenty million dollars
no no this this is last week
so last week he comes out and I guess
like a month ago he was like I'm not
gonna I don't need to raise any more
money I'm not gonna do that then this
week or last week he's like yeah I need
to raise two billion dollars so I'm
gonna sell some stock from the company
issue new stock and sell it but the
stock went up eight billion dollars on
that announcement and so he basically
created rate six billion dollars of
Delta in that transaction plus you get
two billion dollars well both him and
Portnoy I think are loose cannons and
they could get in trouble you think why
do you think porn is gonna be in trouble
for the first wheaten about the stocks
yeah do you see the tweets where he like
puts the asterisk and anything about
stocks I own a [ __ ] ton of yeah I mean
look I get like I think it's funny and I
love it I don't know if the SEC will
find it I mean we'll see what happens
yeah yeah I guess have a lawyer like
really close somebody's gotta be like uh
I don't know we'll see what the SEC
thinks it's funny what other businesses
in the media world are you fascinated by
right now or you think are doing really
interesting to be business publishers
like who there's this company called
informa okay never heard of them yeah
most never have have you heard of them
yeah mo just gave us the now mostly I've
never heard that hasn't heard of it
doesn't exist Google and form a market
cap its traded on the English or England
it traded in England it might be
thirteen billion market cap it says
nothing it's because they're not the
American Stock Exchange okay I think
it's the revenue is three or four or
five billion dollars two point three
seven billion GBP and revenue 2018 and
revenue yes
yeah so I think it's a thirteen billion
dollar company to us what is that USD so
yeah three basically three billion
dollars u.s. and 2018 yeah three and
half four billion and their market cap
is some number between 1015 well what
they do is they make money in a few
different ways primarily two different
ways they own a hundred brands or so
maybe more maybe less and they own
they're mostly b2b things so
for example I think they own this but
let's just might be made up they own
like an agricultural brand that a lot of
farmers no no it's probably more
specific people who buy equipment for
farming okay
whether they're they work at John Deere
or something like that and then they
monetize that through subscriptions then
they have a data side where if you want
to figure out I'm just making this up as
I go if you want to figure out um the
best data on buying different parts and
who's selling the best parts or what the
projection is popular engine component
yeah just like things like information
you need to run your business a little
bit more effectively then they have a
trade show where if you are John Deere
you'll have a booth there and then a guy
who makes the leather seats will have a
booth there and so so you can sell to
each other
yep um so that's how they make money in
three different ways event the actual
data itself and then the content yeah so
a lot of people don't know about it
repoing dollars a lot of money it's
stupidly profitable their trade shows I
did a big report on this trade shows
will do forty percent income yeah I mean
their trade show business brings in
hundreds of millions of dollars in
profit crazy um and so I think they're
really interesting obviously and so with
our company they're kind of like what I
see us becoming so I think that's really
interesting what else I don't know I
just want your free knowledge you taught
me about informal what else you got
there's well there's loads of companies
just like informa that a little bit
smaller a cent tiel a scen
tal ASCE and it's another British
company ASC why are they all in I don't
know they're all in Britain all the
tradeshow pmap is a British
business-to-business media business
specialized yeah that's a lot of
businesses it's a four hundred million
dollar a year top-line 150 million in
income
yep that's cool and they do something
similar they own cans you know cans the
yeah yeah the advertising festival yep
they own that have you heard a that
actually always just struck me as a way
for the people who wanted to go to on
vacation on it is okay have you heard of
money 2020 yep they own that um those
conference businesses are really big and
and there's some guy in California who
created a couple of these and sold them
all
just recently yeah that's him the guy
started money 2020 yeah well who's that
guy he owns shoptalk it's a white
British guy and an Indian guy I think
hold on the guys behind the money 2020
conference
what is this want to do the same thing
in commerce which is this er no it's an
Israeli guy an Israeli guy in an Indian
guy
Anil Agarwal Simran Agarwal and Jonathan
Weiner yeah they do those seem to be
relatives and one not so much
yeah they're cool they're they just sold
they just sold they sold money 2020 for
a hundred million and they sold shoptalk
for 150 it's crazy yeah they're huge big
businesses yeah so I'm really interested
in trade shows and things like that
because I think with the digital age
people want to get together yeah so I
think that's gonna be quite big so that
fascinates me what's the one thing you
learned building the hustle that you
wish you knew at the beginning well just
about building businesses how to control
your emotions and like the UPS I try and
the ups to me are never that high and
the lows aren't low at all now can we
talk for a second let's not use names
unless you want to say the names about
how you wouldn't ended up taking
investment yeah so we've raised money
from Tim Ferriss okay he's gonna say the
names from Scott Belsky
the founders of nerd wallet which and
with that credit Carmen news they could
be maybe the there somebody want to
double down yeah who knows what'll
happen there I mean that's a huge
company
I say Scott Belsky you guys are pants
the founders of bleacher report the
founders of the Chive the founders of a
couple of these old b2b media companies
so a bunch of like media yep walls and
so I didn't mean to raise money
basically I would ask for advice there's
this phrase s-sir advise invest twice so
you I would ask for advice and they'd be
like let me invest and I'd be like well
okay and in my head I was like you know
I was 24 so I didn't know I was doing
but I was like you're gonna give me
money and I get to message you all the
time and ask you questions I pay me to
be my friend basically awesome but
listen to how I met
Tim Ferriss was he lived down the street
from me and we would walk our dogs in
San Francisco yeah we would walk our
dogs in the park and I knew who he was I
was a fan and he just knew me as Sydney
as my dog ass its owner maybe he knew my
name but I don't think he did and we
would just shoot the [ __ ] I didn't want
to like fanboy out too much maybe like
hey just listen your podcast it was good
you know how's Molly I was everything
like beautiful weather just shoot the
[ __ ] and one day I get an email from Tim
and he goes hey I love the hustle can we
meet and talk about email and I go yeah
sure and he goes all right let's do this
restaurant in the neighborhood and I
show up and he goes oh wait you're the
dog's owner Wow totally coincidental
yeah he didn't know what he no no idea
yeah so that's how I met did you think
that he knew no I never mentioned it I
never said of work yeah I loved it and
so that's why I met Tim and so yeah I
just would like I said I research like
crazy so I used whether I wanted you to
teach him about email yeah he went he
went hard on email and I was like yeah
here's what we learned and so he just
comes he's got what is the five bullet
Friday or whatever I think it's become a
pretty big list that he's huge yeah he's
quite big and so now him and I will
trade best practices on nerdy the
technical aspect like you guys should
create a subscription service we're just
people can subscribe to you and Tim
texting that would be awesome we should
like so I'm dead serious right if you
think about like put you and like 20
other media folks in a text thread and
it's like make somehow make it so that
people can only read they can't they
can't actually secreta yeah and then all
you do is you guys just have normal
conversations like hey man what are you
seeing with this but whatever people
would pay you know ten bucks a month and
just see like what are these twenty
people all talking about to build their
businesses and they were just to steal
your idea that's a great idea
but that you know I want people to much
but that's what our podcast is we're
just like shooting the [ __ ] and like
created the text message thing I was I
wanted 50% of revenue but he's already
at the podcast it's similar but that's
that's a funny idea
yeah just I've always been fascinated by
previously if you and I sat down in a
private room like no one would like buy
tickets like listen to us talk right but
actually yeah but like it would be hard
to like actually execute on what do they
pay and all sensor but now that like a
lot of communications digital I actually
think that that's gonna become more
popular over time so it's like how many
companies are you a fan of that you
think is really good at X Y or Z and you
would actually pay to see their internal
communication so let me tell you this I
love that idea and here's why I read a
ton of biographies my favorite biography
two of my favorites are the biography of
Joe Kennedy called patriarch the second
one is Titan by John Rockefeller I was
obsessed with them for different reasons
but I really admired those guys
different aspects Joe Joe Kennedy was a
an [ __ ] of a husband so but I like
little parts of them and we can't pick
and choose here as to what encouraged me
like about people right and so I obsess
over things by brothers biographies and
then they would write letters to their
families and there's other books that
are not well known you got to dig for
them on Amazon and you could see their
correspondence and I love doing that and
so what I love about the digital age
with like this Elon Musk book I'm like
show me those emails I want to see all
those emails back and forth and so it's
really fun when investors like tweet
when in some company sells so here's the
first pitch that they gave me an email
Mike yeah that's awesome you should take
all of your emails like from the
beginning the first five years or
something batch them all up and sell
them to one person there's somebody out
there who would buy it we'll call it
Hillary that I don't care what side
you're on that was a stupid joke joke
there's a little people who pay a lot of
money for those 33,000 emails stupid
joke that's a good idea
yeah all right where people go to the
hustle doc Co the hustle that Co if they
want our free email trends dot Co if
they want our subscription and I'm on
Twitter we all talked all three of us in
this room talk to each other and Twitter
the sampar okay twitter has been my it's
awesome right now and you're a huge on
it well that's all I heard about you
honest honestly I have no clue how no
Twitter does not make more money how
much would you pay to use Twitter a
month dozens of dollars yeah like 20 or
30 I mean a lot I lived you didn't
really think I would pay more than I pay
for Netflix for sure I would like if you
just go down the line of all the things
that you pay subscriptions for Twitter
would probably at the top of the list
for me all three of us met in this room
on tour I met you two on Twitter yeah
you guys been on Twitter yeah she's
talking on the Internet that's awesome
long sigh man we've never told the story
on the podcast one day we're gonna make
her tell it I
I posted on Twitter last night that I'm
gonna be I purposely rented a huge air
B&B and I says I'm gonna have a dinner
with 20 people all I had a hundred
people signed up to come but I like
limited it to only 20 all of them came
from Twitter Twitter's are awesome it's
it succeeds despite itself like yes
Dorsey which actually makes it super
valuable I love that yeah III buy
Twitter stock I think that Jack Dorsey
needs to Allah I like him as a person
because he's weird he should be fired
and reviewed so I'm I'm actually uh and
the opposite camp
I don't think Twitter would be as good
as it is without jack cuz I think that
Jack either intentionally or
accidentally protects it from what it is
so both can be true yeah so look if you
want to look at it as like a platform
that does good for the world then he
should stay if you want to look at it as
clearly just some like Zuck and just get
all money who came out of it yeah he
will not do it
agreed so it depends what you want I as
someone who just wants to use it and I
would sell on my stock yeah great stay
there Jack make it a public service and
that just happens to make a profit all
right
I think Wikipedia Reddit and Twitter and
kora should all be like that yeah that's
fair like just don't milk us try just
keep it like okay yeah well they're too
or at least two if not three of those
are already doing that sounds good um
last few things to talk about Bitcoin
yeah you guys wanna hear cool story okay
so yeah by the way this whole podcast I
really started about Bitcoin I never
talk about me a coin anymore okay this
is a good one so I know it's about a
saying it's so why Oh Justin thirteen no
twelve thousand twelve okay so 2012 I
went to this party it was called an
animal print party so we all wore animal
clothing would you guys I don't know no
I wore like a onesie a onesie like adult
pajama that had like zebra on it okay
and that's a shitty costume but go ahead
I was 20-something 22 I got dressed up I
got it from like dollar stores some of
the dollar store okay so I met this girl
I started talking this girl we were
hitting off I was saying all the time
and we were doing great and you know
this big charming guy walks in and I
like stare at him because he was wearing
like a he was wearing like a
beedo an animal print speedo and here it
was like fit and tall and a good smile
and he steals the girl from me and
starts chatting her up and I end up
start talking to the guy and I made
friends with them yada yada yada and I
friended him on Facebook afterwards and
um we took pictures together okay and I
started following my facebook his name
was Ross and I see uh what I'll tell you
I see on Facebook that he's like selling
his truck for $2,000 because he posted
the Craigslist link I see that he's like
an equities trader and LinkedIn just
whatever
I wasn't like close with him but I hung
out on that day stole your girl yeah
yeah and so a few weeks later maybe a
few months later I come home from my
house I come to my house in Glen Park
and there's police at the library I'm
like what is going on and I and somewhat
Terry my friend sent she was
Sam Ross got arrested I was like for
what he goes you know Silk Road I was
like yeah I know Silk Road she goes he
restarted Silk Road holy SH and I do it
so God was like I do what I do a lot of
Bobby Knight it was just like scary cool
thing that was Ross Ross Albright
Albrecht Albrecht yeah that was him and
the next day in the speedo who stole
your girl started so great it's better
the next day I go to lunch at my office
and I my coworker his name was Billy I
go Billy do you see about the Silk Road
thing it was powered by like this whole
Bitcoin thing and Billy goes yeah my dad
like loves it and he thinks it's gonna
be huge
well Billy's last name Billy Draper was
his name yep and his dad was Tim Draper
and I and his dad kind of had a couple
of Bitcoin yeah Billy like I wasn't that
close to Billy and I try not to talk too
much about father because you know he's
a big deal and you don't want a fanboy
out but Billy was like yeah my dad
thinks it's gonna be cool and I was like
cool I don't know anything about this
but if your dad says it's gonna be good
I did and so I bought a bunch of it and
then for Christmas I bought each of my
family members $200 worth and that
turned into 10 grand and they all
laughed at me at the time and then when
I hit 20 G's like a year and a half ago
I go hey mom
log into that thing called coinbase that
I sent you log into and go take a
vacation and so they all sold it and
took vacations so they sold it I think
they all sold half yeah I know just sell
half and have fun
I was awesome and that's how I heard
about Bitcoin that may be the best story
I've ever heard it's crazy right yeah
and then I read the book American
kingpin and they described my
neighborhood I live in the small
neighborhood in San Francisco that very
few people know about and I was it was
right like I hang like I sit at the lot
at the seat where he sits all the time
that I used to hang out that library his
story of how they got his computer he's
crazy they just rushed him when he liked
ladies with like a like a I think a guy
that like this woman or something yeah
and he was turned around just swarmed
them and they get swarmed him in the
part that I had pause these things they
like yeah that I shoved it across across
the table so he couldn't lock the
computer yeah then they run it to their
van and they plug it into power and
[ __ ] crazy it was badass
and that's my library I literally lived
next door to that it was crazy this was
crazy I still I took the photos down on
Facebook by saved them on my Dropbox
it's pretty wild to me it's like having
pictures with Al Capone you know to me
yeah like I mean regardless if you think
you did or not it's like a famous like
figurehead for a person yeah
do you everything I'll get out I don't
know know where you fall in this and
you're more passionate about Bitcoin I
think that if you try to kill someone
you should go to prison for a really
long time and here's and I also I used
to have these kids that would sell drugs
I lived in soma for a little while and
these these guys would sell drugs and I
hated them for it for they would sell
heroin and I was like you [ __ ] guys
get off my block you're ruining the
neighborhood and then I see him get
arrested I'm like oh he's this nice like
suburban white kid and I'm like wait a
minute no no no no no if I'm mad at
those guys I need to also be mad at this
guy so I think there's a whole thing too
about what drug it is right and I think
this is changing in America in general
like one of the most fascinating trends
right now in culture to me is this idea
that like police departments are
choosing what to decriminalize and what
not to they're not gonna go
decriminalize heroin right like the
hardcore stuff that is very easy to draw
a line to like this is killing people I
think will be illegal for ever if not
for a very very long period of time but
like marijuana right interested like
small possession of possession of small
amounts etc you have some states like
California Colorado etc who just like
look we're from a legislative standpoint
gonna say that this is legal
in some cases or just for anyone but
then you have like the Baltimore Police
who the DA just is like hey guys if you
keep arresting people first I'm not
gonna prosecute I see Francisco yeah
you're [ __ ] wasting your time and that
pisses me off because I lived in that I
lived I lived in Glen Park for most of
the time I've been there for one stint I
went to soma and I came right back and
soma you know my favorites this kept
okay for two years it's trashy I mean
it's bad like that was everywhere I was
one of the smart ones I lived up in the
north part like the Russian Hill okay
all right I lived in Solman every day I
see these same kids they keep bindles of
heroine in their cheek like that I told
this story before I one time recently
was walking in San Francisco about to go
into Starbucks I saw a guy who again I
don't know for sure but it looked like
he's pretty homeless just kind of really
dirty you know clothes kind of jingling
up etc and he knelt down and he put a
coffee cup down he took out an iPhone
put it on top of the coffee cup like he
was holding it there and as I was coming
around the corner to walk in the start
that's kind of looked in it well I was
like what is this guy doing right like
he's like kneeled down outside the store
door and he he had a needle yeah again I
don't know he's actually shooting up
right there or he was just put like
changing his pocket or what do you do it
but I was like in what [ __ ] planet do
we live was the guy's got an iPhone and
a syringe so look at this I lived
outside it was the same it was a group
of kids from Guam Guatemala I think I
forget I got to start talking to my own
kind of understood how they worked and I
was so angry at them because I would see
these I was I I lived there for a few
years and I would see the same the same
people buying drugs I see him get worse
and worse him one day one of them died
on my office door step and I went to
like I was like hey can you please move
my employees are coming and she was dead
okay so I got to know these people and I
[ __ ] hated those drug dealers I hated
I was I don't know who I hated I was
just angry yeah I was pissed off and I
don't know what the right decision is
but I know that if I was if I wanted
those drug dealers arrested which I did
I'm also what you have to yeah I need to
have that towards Ross even though he
was this like romantic good-looking like
free the people type of guy like you
have to have a it's really hard to
separate the actions from the impact
right and I think that there's also
there
this community of like everything should
be legalized like you shouldn't be mad
at people who like create software and
marketplaces and all this stuff but at
the same time then there's this thing of
like well if you know people are selling
drugs and people are getting hurt then
like are you responsible or not which
actually is very similar to like should
Facebook be responsible for the content
that's on there like yeah every
marketplace owner it's a very
challenging problem and and I kind of
really challenged to be honest I'm I'm
kind of a little bit of uh I don't take
as much time to think about as I
probably should so I have like a kind of
stupid answer to this but it's like
that's a super complex issue that's
above my pay grade and I actually don't
know what the answer is which is cop-out
right but like well there is no answer
there's there's let's try this and see
where and there's there's a spectrum of
like there's the hardcore believers on
one end there's a hardcore believers on
another end and there's everyone that's
in the middle and like they all disagree
and that's where you get all of the okay
he tried to kill three people and they
thought he killed one he thought he
killed a couple of them and then kept
going right yeah so like that's a whole
separate issue of course so as much as I
stole your girl like that time I think
it was important part remember it
specifically I don't think but yeah so
my thing is like I loved reading about
his book and I it was such good writing
that I was like yeah go Ross like but
then you gotta like take your emotions
out of it be like I mean yeah so it's
really challenging alright last question
for you
and then you can ask me a question to
end aliens believer non-believer
believer why it just doesn't the math
doesn't work out that like where this
floating rock and this massive existence
and we're the only things that are like
us I think that aliens don't probably
maybe don't exist in the like we think
there's like like the green relation of
you arms like but in terms of living
maybe they don't even live like maybe
the word living doesn't even apply but
like there's some smart thing out there
yeah are you more fearful of what's in
space or what's in the ocean great
question
so both the if you you're like I'm not
[ __ ] with if you said you'd give me a
hundred thousand dollars to go to space
for a day I would not do it for one day
you know we did it nope not
why it's scared I have you're lying I
don't do any drugs I don't drink but
when I fly I take xanax I hate I hate
elevators I don't like flying
like coming up to the 53rd floor here I
did not like what about going down into
the earth if you offered me not a chance
if you offered me 10 grand for a one-day
cruise I wouldn't do it oh just for a
cruise out in the ocean not even a good
a chance not even a chance when I say
both but most people pay to go on the
commune's I think about this a lot I'm
like what is my threshold for a
three-day cruise might be it could be as
high as 60 grand $60,000 somebody could
pay you to go on the boat for three days
I don't even know if I would do it then
so I forget and maybe Joe remembers who
this is but there's this guy on YouTube
he he does like not pranks but like kind
of stunts right and one of them he put a
million dollars in singles in single
single dollar bills into a box and took
four people and put their hand on the
box and said last one to take your hand
off wins the million dollars and they
went for like 72 hours or something you
know like really peeing in bottles and
like the whole nine yards and he films
the whole thing right and it's like this
crazy viral video and so I always think
about like what are other things other
than like keep your hand on a box I'm
like for you would be like you and five
other people who are scared of a cruise
ship put them out literally just far
enough where you could see land but you
can't come back until you tap out unless
I can be heavily medicated I wouldn't do
it if you wouldn't even go help me I've
like it's really bad it like holds me
back like I don't I don't travel a lot
because of it I hate it when the aliens
come I know who not to go hang out with
because you're not hiding anywhere good
what question you have for me to finish
this up you're in the military right I
was what is the single biggest takeaway
it commits me to join the military what
can I learn can't convince somebody okay
um I guess make me tell me let me know
and let me take that back there's a
suspicion is the whole versioning yeah
there's a specific type of person that
you can convince but it's not for the
reasons that most people think so you
can convince 22 and younger men to join
based on danger fun and D like
adrenaline of it all just excitement so
yeah so it's just like
I thought I signed up when I was 17 I
knew I was gonna go to college or do I
was gonna go play football but I signed
up for a contract that basically like
let me go do that and then I was gonna
Oh time but the way that I did it I got
deployed when I was a junior in college
right so they pulled me out of school to
go came back for their school when I was
17 years old how to got my parents to
get them to sign off my dad literally
said to me I'm not [ __ ] getting
involved in this go talk to your mother
she's the one who's gonna like kill me
if I ever sign that paper so my mom was
like no no no finally she agrees and in
hindsight why did I join cuz it was
basically like summer camp but they gave
us guns right like the concept of war
completely not my head like the concept
of danger not my head whatever it was
like dude you're gonna go you're gonna
like do a bunch of physical activity
they're gonna yell at you I was like
let's finish my life anyways it like
football or family whatever and then
they're gonna like teach you how to like
do things in the water or like jump out
of this or you know whatever lets you
shoot like a house like it sounds
[ __ ] awesome like no I would pay
people to go do this I would do it
instead they're gonna pay me like sign
me up so that like very specific age
group you can convince after that it
becomes very politicized very like ethos
driven like there's almost like you
become too smart to be convinced by the
like hey there's a did you regret it no
no at all like it was the best thing
that I did especially because I did it
when I did it wasn't ready for
discipline it was really good I was
pretty disciplined already but I think
what it did was it taught me like the
importance of self discipline right
discipline being like I played football
I went to school like there was a lot of
discipline and structure in my life
already probably cuz my father knew that
I needed that or I be as [ __ ] but
what this taught me I think was more of
like here's the reasons why you should
impose the discipline on yourself and if
you uh what is the guy's name Jocko will
Mick yeah like one of his big things is
like discipline equals freedom and I
think like that's so true but people
don't realize that the discipline
component there is less about like move
your right foot move your left foot and
it's more about having like okay I want
to build a company right I'm gonna
actually spend the time necessary to do
this and I'm not gonna give up right or
I have to go learn certain things etc
and so the military isn't as rigid or
like top-down as people think it is it's
much more like the sergeant shows up to
his team and says hey guys we
gotta go like solve this problem like
how are we gonna do it and so there's a
lot of creativity that goes on but it's
within a strong you're depressed when
you left no not at all I was too dumb to
be like I was I think my hypothesis was
a lot people would get depressed when we
leave because a lot of men don't have
the like when you're in the military you
have a mission and you have camaraderie
yeah so one of the things that I credit
a lot to like a lot of guys that I went
to Iraq with and it all sort of the
military a lot of suicides a ton of guys
got arrested after we got back I mean
literally a guy pistol-whip somebody in
a parking lot you know duis all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] that went on and a lot of it
was like either PTSD specifically or
like similar types of reactions to all
this but for me I went from being a
normal kid to playing football right
which is all male camaraderie semi
violent sport you know all the kind of
us first name etc to the military which
is still all male camaraderie etc for my
unit us first time etc when I came back
I went back to playing football so it
was kind of like an escalation of
violence and camaraderie etc and then a
de-escalation on the way out which at
the time you don't understand right but
in hindsight like super super helpful
for me it's really sad that other people
literally went from we're at war two
weeks later they're like back at their
job as a prison guard at working in a
hardware store etc I have no clue how
those guys dealt with it into I was a
single 21 year old kid like let's go
drink beers and enjoy college type stuff
these guys are going back and like they
have a wife and two kids yeah how do you
go back into that environment I have no
[ __ ] clothes so it makes a lot of
sense why guys have the reactions they
have especially we kind of like the
combat units but I was just super lucky
in that I kind of that de-escalation out
of it good answer
you want to join no I think I would
still get a bonus for signing somebody
up I think I'm too old
howdy I'm thirty thirty I'm older than
you I'm 31 but you can't be you can't
enlist if you're not you can't yeah
there's people who know I I would want
to spend a week or two maybe even like
three or four months getting all the
benefits but none of the downside like
having to risk my life so there I forget
the program I need to come up with I
need to come up with the name of what
this is but there's a
program that basically will put you
through like very very similar to seal
training but it's not the military it's
like a private thing and it's all run by
axials and they they basically know
there's much my thing is like a plane a
young men in America don't exactly have
like a rite of passage from like you're
a boy to you're a man yep and what that
creates is a lot of twenty five thirty
five-year-old boys and I'm like man if I
wish there was this thing yeah it's like
you've accomplished you are now a man
like there's no task there's no journey
so back in oh man I'm gonna get this
wrong I think it's Sparta I read this I
do not know if this is true when did you
go out and like kill a bunch of stuff
like some of those like when you're a
kid they put you out in the winter and
whoever survival was true he's not but I
heard that there was I think it's Sparta
and I think that the person who did this
is dr. SEPA on Twitter he's always
tweeting but they basically made you run
ten miles with water in your mouth and
you couldn't drink the water so when you
got to the end you had to spit it out
that's crazy that's cool I think and my
and like you didn't like we couldn't
today ever imagine somebody doing that
that would be like the most viral video
of all time right and then and then
everyone on the internet would be he
cheated somehow right but like those
types of things around discipline
physical fit right et cetera are very
similar to I think what like the
military provides and I've told played a
million times like I was 17 when I went
to basic training I was 21 I went to war
right you're literally too dumb and too
naive to understand danger one but also
to like when the drill sergeant when
you're 17 years old you like do more
push-ups like Ron whatever you're
literally like oh my football practice
like you just like out what like
everyone my entire life has yelled at me
like this guy versus my parents like
what's the difference this guy could
actually beat me up but my parents
couldn't actually do anything right when
you're 25 or 30 you're like hey man
you're not gonna talk to me that way
right now you always have this like
false sense of like self-importance
right you go and so I was there with
guys were 30 and I'm like how are you
getting yelled like right very very
different life lots of cool answer all
right
the Hustle Co the hustle Co for free
email trends Co if you want to sign up
use p om p for 50% off and the sampar at
the san pat on twitter yeah
he'll DM you and get you to sign up
anyways I will try alright thanks so
much for doing this thank you